maintenant j'ai un silence absolu
[Musique]
assis
silence dans les
couloirs des stands des zones communes
jupes pas plus de deux pouces du
sol lorsque
je m'agenouille si je volais sur le mur de votre
maison que verrais-je que
tu es tout à fait  une influence sur les autres
vous ne devez pas fraterniser avec l'une de
ces filles
qui est la première personne de votre groupe d'âge
à partager des symptômes
vous savez tous que quelque chose ne va pas
[Musique]
avez-vous eu des rapports sexuels
fermez les yeux embrassez vos lèvres
[Musique]
i  ne tolérera pas une telle conduite
sorcières folles
les normes de comportement doivent être
respectées c'est une école ce n'est pas un établissement psychiatrique
oh je ne
suis pas
fou de vieux secrets remontent à la surface
tu es dangereux
[Musique]
personne ne sait qui je  suis plus
ce que je suis vraiment
ce que je pense faire de
toi